I told you yesterday that coronavirus is
spiking in many parts of the country and
we also talked on the bonus show I guess
it was it was either 2 days ago or six
months ago I don't know everything feels
the same it was sometime this week about
how Donald Trump has decided that it is
time to restart huge campaign rallies
massive crowds gathered together
spreading the virus yelling about how
great Donald Trump is and now even more
cartoonishly Donald Trump's first rally
is going to be in Tulsa Oklahoma on June
19th
also known as Juneteenth which Trump is
combining a location that was the site
of a massive racist massacre with a very
important day June 19th is the
anniversary of the Emancipation the
freeing of the last enslaved African
Americans in the Confederacy in federer
see somehow it's 2020 but a big topic
this week Tulsa in 1921 was the location
of a huge racist massacre where mobs of
white people destroyed a predominantly
black Drizzt district called Greenwood
which was called Black Wall Street and
there are a number of different
questions here one is how calculated is
the date and location
Juneteenth in Tulsa Oklahoma by Donald
Trump I think Trump probably knows very
very little about this history but
certainly people like Stephen Miller and
others around Trump probably know more
about this history and to some degree I
think they get off on doing this type of
stuff now the broader public health
question is why is this happening in
Oklahoma at all and the reason is that
Oklahoma starting to allow large events
as part of their coronavirus reopening
do the numbers support this decision in
Oklahoma not really I mean if you look
at the data we're looking at case
numbers Oklahoma is not hugely spiking
it's not really improving though they
have had a pretty steady trickle of
cases for the last three months but
since the start of June Oklahoma has had
its highest three-day average of cases
it is difficult to imagine anyway that a
huge rally
if masks are not required is not going
to lead to a spike in cases now it might
not be huge but there's going to be more
contagion because of a huge rally like
this but it just doesn't matter to the
President or to the administration or to
his campaign they've decided as a
practical matter that coronavirus is
over it's time to rally that's it
there's no more press briefings there's
barely any discussion of coronavirus
they don't talk about deaths they don't
talk about cases other than to lie and
say how great they are now it is not
just Tulsa Oklahoma that Donald Trump
will be going to Donald Trump will be
holding rallies in Florida Arizona and
North Carolina and those are not maybe
it's okay maybe it's not those are
epicenters of disease right now you have
to see this to believe it
these are case growth curves that
absolutely do not suggest that you
should be having huge rallies in these
states especially with people remember
right-wingers are much more likely than
left wingers not to take the virus
seriously not to stay home not to wear
masks not to do the things you need to
do to prevent spreading it and by that
we are likely to see even more spread so
in North Carolina cases have been
steadily increasing and rising North
Carolina does not appear to have peaked
yet it's getting worse and worse and
worse in North Carolina as the days go
by Florida as I told you yesterday had a
dip in cases in late April but that
might have been when they were just
lying about the numbers they have again
peaked with new record case numbers
coming in the first part of June so far
that's not where you want to be doing
huge rallies and then you've got Arizona
Arizona maybe with the worst trendline
of any of these states cases were sort
of low in Arizona for months slow
increase and since the start of June
just a massive spike to cases in Arizona
Arizona is close to one of the worst
places in the country where you should
be having a mass rally there in danger
of running out of ICU beds all of a
sudden and that's where Donald Trump
wants to go spoke to a friend who lives
in Arizona this morning
told me that no one's wearing masks
unless it's absolutely required and that
it's not really required almost anywhere
even most indoor places and the nursing
homes are having a real real issue in
Arizona it's almost like Trump's
choosing the worst places and this could
work to get coronavirus to some rural
communities we've been talking a lot
about you know coronavirus has been
centered around cities because that's
where you have more people cities tend
to have more direct flights to China and
to Europe that made it early epicenters
were likely going to be in cities rural
folks will come to Tulsa Oklahoma
they'll come to you know Phoenix or
wherever and then they'll bring the
virus back out to rural areas people
there will get the virus but those rural
areas have a far lower hospital capacity
and dramatically lower ICU capacity and
you can imagine the way it's all going
to go now meanwhile just to show you
that things can be handled properly take
a look at Switzerland's curve
Switzerland has had under 100 new cases
per day since five weeks ago very few
deaths it's just one example it can be
done look at you know look at Iceland
look at there's so many different
examples we'll get of course Taiwan but
you really need competent leadership you
need fewer really dumb people and
unfortunately here in the United States
we lack leadership and I mean let's face
it we have a lot of ignorance we have a
lot of ignorance and that is a bad
combination I want to remind you that
Tuesday we are doing something nice to
build community so much news is negative
these days we are having the second
david pakman show chess tournament I
will be playing in the tournament I want
you to play in it all skill levels are
welcome it's free this is just totally
free we're just running this for
community sake it will be on the website
elite chess org that's li chess dot
o-r-g you can sign up on the website now
I will be tweeting out the link to the
tournament probably 7:45 p.m. Eastern on
Tuesday the 16th the tournament will
start at 8:00 and it will run somewhere
around 75 to 90 min
so make sure you are I hope you
participated we had 500 people play last
time I would love to double it if
possible also remember you can follow me
on Twitter at D Pakman at D Pakman on
Twitter and remember if you tend to
watch YouTube clips but you want to get
a daily podcast there's the free daily
podcast of the David Pakman show one
hour long it's on iTunes Spotify Pandora
Google Play stitcher all of these
different places you can get it there if
you love feeding your intellectual
curiosity but you're always struggling
to find the time check out one of my
all-time favorite apps called blink it's
blink Isleta consume an entire book on
your way home from work
they take thousands of popular
nonfiction books condense each one into
text or audio that you can get through
in just 15 minutes and you get all of
the important core ideas and information
from that book it's perfect if you don't
have enough time to do all the reading
you want to do or if you just want to
sample a book before you buy the entire
thing I recently read a brief history of
time of course by the great Stephen
Hawking this is a book that I have been
aware of for so long and other things
got in the way and it was fantastic to
check it out on blinkin
blink east has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different nonfiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25%
off a subscription when you go to blink
is comm slash Pakman I've put the link
right underneath this video